this is a Fox News Alert the House
Intelligence Committee due to meet
behind closed doors at this hour and
could vote as soon as this evening on
whether to release that secret memo the
Republicans say shows surveillance
abuses by the Obama administration DOJ
and FBI keep it on Fox News for the
latest developments on this breaking
story
in other news on Friday after the New
York Times reported that Hillary Clinton
helped protect the senior adviser to her
2008 presidential campaign who was
accused of sexually harassing a young
subordinate she responded tweeting she
was dismayed when it occurred but
heartened that the woman came forward
meanwhile a video surfaced over the
weekend of Clinton thanking her
supporters hey everyone I just wanted to
say thanks thanks for your feminism for
your activism and all I can hope is you
keep up the really important good work
but then things took an even more
bizarre turn watch let me just say this
is directed to the activists supporting
let's go all right well and it doesn't
end there Clinton resurfaced again
during surprise appearance during last
night's Grammys doing what else
well mocking President Trump he had a
longtime fear of being poisoned one
reason why he liked to eat it with
[Applause]
all right Kennedy please decipher all of
this for Wow what comedic genius it's
very funny because she's not the only
Democrat that's trying to use a potty
mouth in order to reach out to young
voters yes the great thing about young
voters though is they're not reaching
back to either party they're not
interested and so when we hear these
stories about Bern Strider
and how he was harassing a young staffer
Hilary Clinton the champion of women
with her disingenuous tweets coming out
saying that she was so proud of the
woman that that she called her this week
and what to threaten her with a legal
action right to somehow you know maybe
pay her off or imply that the woman was
going to be protected to make sure she
wouldn't come forward with more of the
story what it says to me is you have
four people who were associated with the
campaign deeply entrenched and there
were senior staffers on the campaign who
wanted Strider out of there and he was
not fired he was not taken off the
campaign it shows me that you've got a
lot of Democrats who are doing whatever
they can to bury her to make sure
there's plenty of room for a full
Democratic field in 2020 that does not
include her name very interesting
because the other said they don't want
to lose again because losing isn't fun
but winning us it is yes let's talk
about the Grammys you wanna yeah which
is short for a grandmother so uh you
know last night's ratings they dropped
10 million households 33 they lost 33%
in the prime demo so wherever she goes
she loses and I'm waiting for her to
blame that on the Russians and that the
Russians actually tinkered with the
ratings the interesting thing about the
reading of the book it wasn't just her
they act had other musical artist I
think cher did it I think I can't
remember the other boo Snoop Dogg so
they the excerpts were about Donald
Trump being bored in meetings and about
what he eats so has the height of
hypocrisy if you've ever read a tour
writer of a pop star who demand yo five
bottles of champagne and a donkey
there's no more petulant self-involved
behavior than a pop star
so the end of at the funny thing is that
that there like like you know this
they'll demand the color of the
furniture the exact type of roses
are spoiled right so ridicule I mean
ridiculous rump because he gets bored in
a meeting that's like a crab calling me
crabby it's it's absolutely nuts and
then to top it off so this is they're
having a relevant discussion about
sexual harassment about the me2 movement
and they include hillary in this who has
protected a serial harasser now twice
her husband and the campaign guy that
was out she overruled when they wanted
in a fire plus if you don't forget this
this is probably even worse the fact
that she said that the Charlie Hebdo
victims had sparked their own murders by
drawing Mohammed so she's always blaming
the victim so the hypocrisy here is is
insane there's a lot more going on there
that that there were certain they
dedicated time to certain musical
artists that passed away that had
interesting backstories that would not
fit into the me2 movement I just hope
God Feld never gets a hold of my riders
[Laughter]
must be up the Grammys they also read
from shattered or unlikable and some of
those those Hillary books that have
painted an unflattering picture I think
Hillary cheapens the whole me to
movement look what she's done she's been
credibly accused of covering up sexual
misconduct on her husband's campaign in
her husband's white house her own State
Department and now her own campaign the
people in her orbit Kevin Spacey
Harvey Weinstein whom his husband I'm
not even gonna say his name and then
like you said she's been married to it
he's a weiner serial sexual harassment
exactly but she's been a total hypocrite
for so many years look she said that
Donald Trump was colluding with the
Russians and then got caught paying a
foreign agent to collude with the
Russians she said Trump wasn't going to
accept the results of the election then
didn't accept the results of the
election she said Benghazi was a better
YouTube video when she knew it was about
terrorism she had a terrible weekend
that tweet that she sent out was
ridiculed by the right and the left so
she was forced into this weird video at
dinner after a few drinks and she said
the [ __ ] line which was totally lame
trying to sound relevant and then she
gets wheelchair doubt too
this little stunt at the Grammys crooked
Hillary tanks the ratings
she should have read the passage wasn't
it wolf who accused nikki Haley is
sleeping with President Trump to get to
the top Hillary didn't say anything
about that she forgot that passage
mm-hmm yes and thank you Haley was none
too pleased no that all right so one you
seem a little bit expressionless for you
during this montage
because I was looking for a sign
sometimes Kimberly it's just too much
apparently nobody heard she lost the
election true you're right nobody knows
about people on the Trump campaign using
profanity or scaramouche II coming out
with all kinds of awful statements about
people and suggesting that people
perform unnatural side with you I mean I
don't know but I guess this is one side
of the political fray so let's go you're
saying use the line for appropriate line
just telling you that people all over on
both sides look at their chirping now
because they realize they've been stung
let me just say this to me is an example
of guess what she's reading something
comedic from Michael Wolf's book America
is reading the book so how do you
suggest that that is somehow Hillary
Clinton and evidence of her hypocrisy my
gosh it's not written by a liberal who's
written by a conservative and it's funny
because guess what they have won Grammys
awards for book reading and so you have
people reading from the Trump book I
think it was funny the one you make a
great point she did lose so given the
choice in October 16 would you rather be
the president and have a bad book
written about you or would you rather be
the loser on an awards show that is
losing viewers you would choose to be
president and not her so it is kind of a
pathetic solo performance
[Applause]
you guys are so in need of somebody to
tear down and to whip up on because you
don't you can't you haven't mentioned
Trump in the face without lie and what
did she do with the woman came to her
and said you know what this guy's
behaved inappropriately we think you
should let him go she said you know what
let's get this guy into treatment and
it's good thing the young woman kept the
record when he went there he only lasted
a few months because he did the exact
same thing so the treatment didn't
exactly work so even when it's the woman
who sprains her arm patting herself on
the back for listening to women and
saying we all deserve to be heard yeah
all those voices deserve to be heard
unless there are people who have accused
her husband or people around her of
sexual I think people defend their
families in the husband's case but in
this case I think you should not go
full-bore and say oh just because
someone's charged you know what let's
have fair process even in big companies
Kennedy people are allowed to speak and
spend them second I'll shoot this guy so
you took the appropriate and legal steps
if you're asking me shirts against the
advice of her campaign chairwoman I said
they should that's fine but I think that
ultimately this is a point where
conservatives because it looks like
liberal hypocrisy I would just point out
that you scored on yourself
no no well yeah we're discussing this
last week I thought this had taken place
in the 2016 campaign
turns out this is back to 2008 well it
doesn't make it okay whether it's 2008
had been through in light of her husband
right I think we know enough in 2008 to
shield people like you're stretching
because I don't think there's any doubt
this is me to moment in America right
now yes we've never seen and you know
it's running for president knows better
than pretty much everyone else in the
country it's actually how to protect
other women or I mean she should
especially if she claims shirt is not
stellar to say the least in this area
that's why it says Hillary's hypocrisy
because as it relates to protection of
women and sexual assault and sexual
harassment obviously she must all of
those scattered teachable moments that
her husband tossed out in front of her
oh that's what you're after the husband
so you're not really even talking about
talking about Hillary Clinton's needs to
a block what does it talk about here
sexual harassment if you marry and the
advisor you guys one last point you know
we were talking about it seeing all
these arenas expressing gender equality
and it's very touching to see but who
expresses gender equality more would you
say Fox News or would you say the music
industry or the Grammys the grandmas the
Grammys awarded seven seventy percent of
their award winners were women most of
the women there weren't allowed solo
performances right she was she was
nominated for the only person nominated
it was not invited to and no she wasn't
invited you know not not to sing a solo
prefer red my point is waiver male
counterparts okay there were a lot of
opportunities there that that a there's
a lot of hypocrisy ed Sheeran was
nominated with four other women he beat
those four other women and said they had
he also won the Grammy though I saw that
terrible joke coming anyway my point is
seventy percent of the awards were won
by women and they're - they can't
lecture us anymore
I'm sorry they I think these award shows
have to take a timeout there's too many
of them they're trapped in their own
myopic emotional world and they don't
understand what the what America is
seeing we just look at this and we're
going shot up we just want to see the
bands
okay myopic excellent use of the word
and also your pronunciation was spot-on
thank you this pleases me